christian dürr für die fdp-fraktion und
wir machen sofort weiter hier im in der
west lobby des deutschen bundestages und
ich freue mich dass bei mir sind an
joschka broker stellvertretende
vorsitzende der fraktion bündnis 90/die
grünen und johann wadephul ist bei uns
der fraktionsvize der cdu csu fraktion
beide sind spezialisten für das thema
außen und sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik und deswegen
natürlich an diesem morgen ganz
besonders gefragt frau broker wenn sie
entscheiden könnten ganz nach eigenen
vorstellungen völlig frei von äußeren
einflüssen welche entscheidungen würden
sie heute treffen die entscheidung die
wir auch getroffen haben in der
bundesregierung nämlich die ukraine mit
all dem was nur irgendwie möglich ist
jetzt in diesen schwierigen stunden
unter diesen brutalen angriffs krieg mit
den leidenden menschen zu unterstützen
und die härtesten sanktionen zu
verhängen die es je gab und auch die
lieferung von waffen zu genehmigen wie
einig sind sie sich da in ihrer partei
insgesamt oder ganz rechts aus der
fraktionssitzung es gab wirklich
einhellige unterstützung für diesen kurs
es wird ja auch gleich eine gemeinsame
entschließung des bundestages geben von
den koalitionsfraktionen aber auch
gemeinsam mit der opposition und ich bin
wirklich sehr dankbar dass es gelingt an
diesem schwierigen tag auch ein solches
starkes zeichen der einigkeit aus dem
deutschen parlament der solidarität mit
der ukraine und der der wirklich größten
verurteilung dieses zentralen
angriffskrieges auszusenden und der
gesamten opposition oder mit großen
teilen der opposition müssten was müssen
müssen wir mal beobachten der
demokratischen ob sie müssen wir
beobachten im laufe der sitzung die um
11 uhr beginnt
herr wadephul die ihre frühere
parteivorsitzende und für ihre
verteidigungsministerin hat dieser tage
getwittert ich bin so wütend darf uns
weil wir historisch versagt haben wir
haben nach georgien krim und don was
nichts vorbereitet was putin wirklich
abgeschreckt hätte wie wütend sind sie
ja den mut kammer die wut kann man
verstehen dass es schon richtig wir
hätten mehr machen können und müssen das
ging nicht wieso ging es nicht nur die
politischen mehrheiten dafür waren nicht
da wir haben auch immer wieder in der
letzten koalition versucht die spd zu
überzeugen mehr zu machen da gab es
widerstand sie haben die kanzlerin
gestellt die kanzlerin gestellt die
kanzlerin hat es auch unterstützt wir
haben immer wieder sagt wales gilt die
berühmten zwei prozent es muss mehr
ausgegeben werden für es war schwer
durchzusetzen aber wir sind jetzt an
einem verkäufer wir sind an einem neuen
punkt wir unterstützen gerne das was die
koalition jetzt macht weil in der
situation nicht nur die internationale
gemeinschaft sondern auch der bundestag
im demokratischen spektrum zusammen
stehen muss und wir hören ja auch aus
der ampel wirklich glaubwürdige zusagen
für die bundeswehr für die zukunft und
da müssen wir gemeinsam anpacken ich
glaube das ist auch eine gemeinsame
aufgabe jetzt einfach die
verteidigungsfähigkeit deutschlands zu
verbessern das ist wichtig das ist
essentiell lebenswichtig im engeren
sinne sogar für uns und ich denke da
gibt es auch gemeinsamkeiten
ich möchte diese wut überwinden durch
produktivität in die zukunft muss ich
sind einen punkt natürlich trotzdem
sagen auch die bundeskanzlerin hat nur
zwei sehr unterstützt also das werden
wir dann auch nicht vergessen also
das will das will niemand bestreiten das
hat wirtschaftsminister gabriel sehr
nach vorne gestellt weil sich so in die
richtung spd jetzt nach er schlug ich
meine das will ich schon noch sagen
erstens wirtschaftsminister gabriel kann
man auch spd-vorsitzender damals klammer
zu hat wesentlichen aus zwei protegiert
die kanzlerin hat das mitgemacht das
muss man in der tat einräumen und auch
in der tat haben wir natürlich die
koalitionsfrage über den
verteidigungshaushalt nicht gestellt das
kann man im nachhinein bedauern aber
maximalen druck haben wir schon immer
gemacht also die bundeswehr ist wichtig
guck mal nach vorne frau bürger wie
bewerten sie denn die entscheidungen die
jetzt getroffen worden sind und was
erwarten sie von dem oder was erhoffen
sie zumindest von denen dass sie
wirklich etwas bewirken dass russland
und wladimir putin die angriffe auf die
ukraine einstellen in absehbarer zeit
wir müssen jetzt wirklich alles dafür
tun um einzuwirken darauf dass diese
brutale gewalt aufhört und dass die
menschen in der ukraine sich selbst
verteidigen und selbst schützen können
und natürlich wirken die sanktionen
nicht von heute auf morgen aber sie sind
sehr hart sie werden auch die russische
wirtschaft in aller härte treffen über
die frage
technologietransfer zugang zu
technologien bis hin zu der abkoppelung
von banken und natürlich ist die
hoffnung dass es auch gelingt ein
starkes zeichen der weltgemeinschaft
auszusetzen auszusenden angesichts der
beratungen den vereinten nationen das
ist wirklich der bruch des völkerrechts
und wenn die berichte waren über den
einsatz von streumunition dann ist es
auch der bruch des humanitären
völkerrechts und hier kann man auch als
weltgemeinschaft nicht einfach zuschauen
deshalb ist es richtig hier eine sehr
breite allianz der entschiedenheit in
der entschlossenheit weltweit zwischen
warum herr wadephul helfen die
waffenlieferungen jetzt mitte der woche
hatte sie noch gesagt ich glaube sogar
bei uns jetzt kommt eigentlich zu spät
man hätte für sie viel früher die
waffenlieferungen waffen liefern müssen
an die ukraine wenn ich es richtig in
erinnerung habe na ja wir haben dafür
früher plädiert das zu machen neben vor
zwei wochen hier eine debatte im
deutschen bundestag gehabt wo die
unionsfraktion schon dafür plädiert hat
waffenlieferungen aufzunehmen damals gab
es noch widerstand jetzt geschieht es
ist nie zu spät es gibt ja erstaunlichen
widerstand der ukrainischen armee und
wenn wir dazu einen beitrag leisten
können dann sind wir glaube ich
politisch moralisch verpflichtet das zu
machen was sind ihre erwartungen das ist
alles ob das aufgeht dieselbe frage dich
jemand freiburger aufgestellt hat es
gibt ja eine solidarisierung mit der
ukraine die die überwältigend ist und
zwar nicht nur in der westlichen welt da
auch überall demonstration sondern sogar
innerhalb russlands innerhalb auch viele
nachbarstaaten viele dort merken da wird
ein bruder volk angegriffen ohne
wichtigen grund sogar noch mit einer
perfiden begründung man müsste eine
entnazifizierung vorantreiben also ich
glaube die der schuss im wahrsten sinne
des wortes kann für putin auch nach
hinten losgehen
die bundeskanzler freiburger hat von
einer zeitenwende gesprochen in einer
erklärung gestern
ich habe vorhin in der moderation schon
mal gesagt das außen- sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik müssen im grunde
vom kopf auf die füße gestellt werden
beziehungsweise völlig neu ausgerichtet
werden was ist das dringlichste was in
deutschland passieren muss wir müssen
auf jeden fall sehr klar haben was hier
gerade passiert ein brutaler
angriffskrieg auf unserem kontinent wir
müssen die maßnahmen zum schutz des
bündnisgebietes und so auch unsere nato
partnerinnen und partner verstärken auch
dazu ist ja eine reihe sind ja eine
reihe von
maßnahmen auf den weg gebracht worden
und natürlich müssen wir dafür sorgen
dass sicherheit uns mehr wert ist und
zwar sicherheit in all ihren dimensionen
da geht es natürlich um den
verteidigungsetat aber auch um energie
souveränität um diplomatie um
entwicklungszusammenarbeit und
humanitäre hilfe wenn wir natürlich auch
das sehen was gerade an der grenze
passiert aber im vordergrund der
wohlstand jetzt zu stehen die bundeswehr
völlig neu aufzustellen als das wie es
in den vergangenen fast jahrzehnten oder
fragen zu sagen aber zumindest zwei
jahrzehnten der fall gewesen ist hat man
sich auf auslandseinsätze konzentriert
hat jetzt zurück wie der bündnis und
landesverteidigung in den vordergrund
was ist nötig und was ist schnell
realisierbar naja die landes- und
bündnisverteidigung haben wir schon 2014
wieder nach vorne gestellt und mit
trendwenden begonnen aber das muss
konsequent fortgeführt werden es ist
alles am ende gar nicht so schwer dieser
tage hat ein rüstungsunternehmen aus
deutschland 50 flugabwehr panzer der
ukraine zur verfügung gestellt oder
gesagt sie könnten sie erwerben hier
könnte auch deutschland sofort kaufen
und dann hätten wir wieder eine
fähigkeit die uns jetzt fehlt ich sage
das nur als beispiel dafür
es gibt ganz einfache schnelle maßnahmen
damit deutschland wirklich wieder eine
bundeswehr hat die das erfüllen kann was
ihr kernauftrag ist nämlich deutschland
zu verteidigen und das bündnis üblich zu
verteidigen ist eine
sicherheitspartnerschaft mit russland im
moment vorstellbar es ist für mich auf
absehbare zeit nicht vorstellbar
wladimir putin hat nicht nur mit diesem
brutalen angriffs krieg die menschen in
der ukraine attackiert sondern hat
eigentlich wirklich zersprengt was über
jahrzehnte unser verständnis von
sicherheit in europa ausgemacht hat
nämlich über rüstungskontrolle über
abrüstung über diplomatie und gespräche
gemeinsame sicherheit für alle zu
zu organisieren und das ist wirklich
eine zäsur was heißt das für die nato
erwartet die nato hat eine neue
berechtigung willkommen viele staaten
wollen hinein das bekenntnis zur nato
ist in allen mitgliedstaaten sehr groß
sie ist nicht wie trainer gesagt hat
obsolet sondern wichtiger denn je
es fiel ging gestern einmalanmeldung rum
die der ukraine als beitrittskandidat
für die europäische union zu benennen
oder in augenschein zu nehmen oder sich
das ganze vorzustellen wie realistisch
ist eine solche idee und was würde sie
bedeuten für den innerhalb dieses
konflikts jetzt also jetzt unmittelbar
sozusagen stehen ganz andere fragen im
vordergrund aber natürlich all die
argumente mit denen man zu der frage
dato beitritt eu perspektive für die
ukraine bisher argumentiert hat auch die
stehen in frage auch hier hat sich die
lage vollkommen verändert und natürlich
gehört die ukraine zu unserem europa
dazu und braucht die solidarität aller
europäischen staaten jetzt mehr denn je
die ihre sicht ja ich glaube das ist
vollkommen klar wir müssen zur ukraine
stehen aber jetzt die illusion zu wecken
dass die ukraine morgen in die nato
eintreten
auch in die eu beides erfordert
voraussetzungen die wir jetzt nicht
sofort erhöhen kann ich glaube es gibt
andere möglichkeiten die ukraine zu
unterstützen und dafür zu sorgen dass
sie stabil ist die eu ist immer darauf
ausgerichtet
auch die staaten aufzunehmen die zu ihr
kommen wollen ich glaube das wichtigste
signal wäre jetzt zum beispiel auf dem
westlichen balkan voran zu kommen da
gibt es etliche staaten die zu uns
kommen wollen das kann man schnell das
kann man zügig machen wir sind das
merkten wir jetzt in einem wettstreit
mit russland übrigens auch mit china und
der westen muss ein zahn zulegen die
bundesregierung der bundeskanzler hat
lange gezögert so heißt es immer was
beispielsweise den das einbeziehen von
swift in die sanktionsliste
angeht nun hat man sich dafür
entschieden
wird das erreichen oder denken sie es
müssen noch sehr viel härtere sanktionen
folgen in absehbarer zeit
es wird wirklich alles geprüft was
möglich ist natürlich sind emotionale
tweets immer schnell abgesendet aber die
bundesregierung muss dafür sorge tragen
dass solche sanktionen wirklich auch
wirken dass sie zielgenau diejenigen
treffen die auch dadurch bestraft werden
sollen dass sie rechtssicher sind und
dass wir die kollateralschäden
beherrschen und diese maßnahmen auch
durchhalten könnte ich glaube es wird
eine kontinuierliche debatte geben was
die nächsten maßnahmen sein werden ihr
vorsitzender merz hat vor nicht allzu
langer zeit noch von der atombombe in
anführungszeichen gesprochen swift
bedeuten würde auch das war ja bedenken
dass es die falschen trifft auch seitens
der bundesregierung und des kanzlers
jetzt alternativlos ja wir müssen das
jetzt machen das wird uns auch treffen
darauf hat friedrich merz hingewiesen
dass muss man sehen aber habe ich meine
wenn wir sehen was die ukraine in kauf
nimmt dann sind das marginale schäden
die wir hier zu gewärtigen haben wir
müssen jetzt wirklich für die freiheit
und für den frieden wirklich alles in
die waagschale werfen und dazu gehört
zwölft in jedem fall dazu oder
relativieren sich dann manche dinge und
nichtsdestotrotz können wir die die
auswirkungen von all dem was jetzt im
moment angestoßen werden und eben die
bahn gebracht wird natürlich überhaupt
nicht absehen erwartet vielen dank der
sich heute morgen bei uns gewesen sind
auch ihnen frau broker vielen dank sie
dürfen jetzt in aller ruhe rein gehen
den sitzungen hat noch nicht angefangen
tut es aber gleich deswegen dürfen sie
sofort losgehen vielen dank ihnen dass
sie heute morgen hier gewesen sind